Henderson international school held a
Lunar New Year parade today the students
carried Chinese lanterns and the dragon
monster the students also wore the color
red as Legend tells the story that the
dragon was frightened by the bright
color if you'd like to join in on the
Lunar New Year celebrations all across
town there will be a festival tomorrow
and Sunday in the Chinatown Plaza with
vendors entertainment and food trucks
that's 11 to 8 Saturday 1-8 on Sunday
tickets are free if you register we do
have a link for you here on our screen
and remember you can also visit the
Bellagio to check out its gorgeous
display dedicated to the year of the
rabbit here's a live look now it's open
24 hours a day the display will be up
through March 4th